a little piece of the UK in the heart of
Berlin's Kreutz back district broken
English has sold groceries and souvenirs
from the island nation for 24 years
Dale Carr a native Britain has spent
almost half her life in this shop now
she is retiring but cannot find anyone
who wants to take over the shop in this
era of brexit trying to make a living
selling imported goods from Britain
seems just too risky I'm not sure who
would take the chance at the moment of
finding ourselves in a position where
they're not able to get hold of the
stock that's required I mean there is a
possibility which we thought of
ourselves a possibility of perhaps going
through Ireland but of course Island as
its own issues of the moments as well so
it's just simply not knowing
ever since the brexit referendum two and
a half years ago
Britain's leaving the EU has been a
constant topic of conversation here in
broken English in order to remain EU
citizens many of dáil cars customers
have taken on German citizenship
including the shopkeeper herself what is
your view on the bracket oh dear well my
own personal view is that it's a
terrible mistake that the UK isn't
making I simply do not understand the
politics behind it or what they possibly
think will be better brexit is to blame
for her now giving up a clearance sale
began this week in broken English this
is like home you know you walk in look
at the environment here it's really nice
it's very quaint it's really in one here
I think it's a real shame I think it's
very sad but I guess you can't really
help what the effects of this sunset he
makes it very hard for businesses to
carry on horrible I need the tea from
here I need the sweets from here and
whenever one of my English friends has a
birthday I buy presents here the
greatest present for Dale car would be
an excerpt from the brexit as unlikely
as that may be she still holds out hope
490